is Donald Trump knowingly acting as an
agent of the Russian government or is he
just such a stooge that it only looks
that way by accident we are running out
of other explanations and we need an
explanation now about an investment
banker named Carter page he did not come
up in this week's debate too much time
was wasted because of the defective
automatic sniffling microphone they gave
the Republican nominee but Carter page
should have come up and we need him
explained by you Trump because Carter
page is one of your guys because Yahoo
News is reporting that US intelligence
agents are sifting through reports that
page has met with a top aide to the
Russian dictator Vladimir Putin in
Moscow who is Putin's deputy chief for
internal policy and who is believed to
be responsible for the information
collected by the Russian intelligence
agencies about the u.s. presidential
vote translation your guy reportedly met
with the Russian guy spying on our
election in Moscow this is a problem
Trump this is your problem and before
you say your people have resolved this
because Kellyanne Conway said he's not
part of our national security or foreign
policy briefings that we do now at all
certainly not since I have become
campaign manager if he's doing that he's
certainly not doing it with the
permission or knowledge of the campaign
and activities that you described or
because another guy said that relative
to the campaign Carter page quote has no
role we are not aware of his activities
past or present
what your toady's just said about page
Trump is different from what a different
toady said about page last month when
she called him your informal advisor and
it is also different than what Carter
page now tells a columnist from the
Washington Post that he is taking a
leave of absence from his work with the
Trump campaign due to the controversy
and that his travels to Russia this past
July again quoting page said he made it
clear that he was acting in his personal
capacity and not as a member of the
Trump campaign so now all four of these
quotes are different from what you said
Trump in March the Washington Post asked
you for the names of your foreign policy
team
the second guy you named was Carter
Paige who our spies think met with
Russian operatives in an attempt to
undermine US policy who is on your
foreign policy team or isn't on your
foreign policy team or is an informal
advisor or is acting without the
campaign's knowledge but he has to take
a leave of absence from the foreign
policy team he's not on we already know
Trump about the day you encouraged the
Russians during a live news conference
to hack Hillary Clinton's emails to you
know commit a kind of electronic age
international version of Watergate that
would have benefited you and we know how
you tried to worm your way out of that
by calling it sarcasm and we already
know about our governments reported
belief that the Russians have already
hacked into the Democratic computers a
conclusion you mocked during the debate
suggesting the real culprit might be a
400-pound guy sitting on a bed and we
already know about the day you looked
like a complete [ __ ] when you said
Putin a dictator was a greater leader
than President Obama because Putin who
is a dictator at higher approval ratings
because you're too stupid to realize
that the approval ratings in Russia for
the Russian dictator may not exactly be
legit and we already know about your
second campaign manager this slimy
Manafort guy and the strings that
connect him to Putin and a pro-russian
political party in Ukraine but we need
to know about this Carter page and why
his name was the second one on your lips
when you were asked for your foreign
policy advisers because Trump you
probably won't understand any of this
but Carter page may have also done
something even worse than allegedly
meeting with the Russian in charge of
spying on our presidential election
Yahoo News also reported the government
is investigating whether your man Carter
Paige also met with somebody in the
Russian hierarchy who talked about
possibly lifting our economic sanctions
against the Russians if you become
president that talk which might itself
violates federal law Carter Paige says
of all this quote all of these
accusations are just complete garbage
which would be easier to believe Trump
if your campaign had not put out four
separate statements about who he is and
what
is doing for you you have to explain
this Buccaneer now Trump because if you
don't if you don't explain the
continuing embrace you have of a
murderous regime of a malevolent country
like Russia
you will face far bigger questions than
just who is Carter page those questions
are simply these Trump do you believe
our elections are sacrosanct and must
not under any circumstances be
influenced by any other government Trump
do you already have a deal in place to
reward a country that may have already
hacked the political party of your
opponent in this election Trump are you
loyal to the concept of democracy Trump
are you loyal to the United States of
America that's the closure I'm Keith
Olbermann watch this space